the whole of cosmology and physics
should be expressed in terms of pure
numbers now you can say Newtons when he
introduced time and distance so the
Greeks always said ratios must be of the
same things so you can take ratios of
two lengths and then you've got a pure
number but Newton introduced time as
well as length so the velocity is a
distance divided by a Time DX by DT and
that's an improper ratio so I want to
build up what I call shape Dynamics
using only ratios of really I would say
of lengths that's all I think you need
you could probably just get by or you
can get a very long way with a very
interesting Theory just using points in
euclidean space